[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: Hello, and
welcome, everyone.
Thank you for joining us.
We are excited to be
here, and we really
appreciate the
effort, especially
at that hour after lunch.
We know it's not as easy
as the early morning hours.
We're here today
to share with you
what's new and cool and
interesting in the new platform
of the Google Assistant.
At Google, as we heard
in the keynote earlier,
we believe that the
future is AI first.
And what does it mean?
It means that we invested
a lot in machine learning,
natural language processing,
and understanding context
and what the user want.
And it's all boiled down and
coming into that assistant.
It's basically a way for you to
have a conversation with Google
and get things done.
And the beauty of
this new platform
is that basically
it's everywhere.
So from really small
devices up to cars.
And very soon we're going
to have many more devices.
It's going to be everywhere.
Why?
It's one of the most
important question
that every time when
we have a new platform
or a new system we ask ourself.
And there are obvious
questions and obvious answers
to this new platform, like it's
write once, run everywhere.
It's very efficient.
It is a great way
to get things done.
But to me personally,
there are two things
that I think if I
were in your shoes,
I would look at
it very carefully.
One is the productivity aspect.
You could really help your
users interact with your service
and get to the result
that they want efficiently
and without too much trouble.
And second, like the
photo up there, it's
a blue ocean right now, so
think about the early days
in each big new revolution.
You could be one
of the first there.
And we'll touch a
bit on it later.
It's a great way for you to
be there with a quality app
and then reach more users.
So what does it mean
for us as developers?
There are a lot of new terms.
And it's great to understand
at the beginning what we mean
with each and every component.
So first and foremost,
we have the surfaces.
Right now we have the
Google Home device,
which is a smart speaker
that the Assistant
is embedded in it.
And it lets you talk and
get things done with it.
And of course, mobile
devices, Android, iPhones--
it's embedded there.
The Google Assistant is
basically the conversation
that you are doing with Google.
And like we saw in
the impressive demos
in the keynote, lots of
new interesting things
to communicate and to
express what are the intent
and what we want to do and get
the results very efficiently
and quickly back to you.
Action on Google is the way
to expose this new Assistant
platform to
third-party developers,
to you, so you could tap into
the investment that we did
and leverage it
when you are coming
to serve your
services and product
and you hand them to your users.
The major important
aspect here to remember
is that when you
interact with the system,
it's very straightforward.
It's a conversation.
And when you want to handle
your service and your users,
you basically burst with OK,
Google, or hey, Google, talk
to, and then you'll give it
your specific brand name or app
so your users from that on
will move and be in your hands,
and you could interact
with them and do--
and help them reach the
goal that you want to.
So how does the
Assistant app work?
And again, it's very
important the beginning
to have the basic understanding
of the moving parts here.
And then everything
become much clearer.
So as you can see
here, in our example,
we did a small demo app that
is called Personal Chef that
give you suggestion to a
recipe based on your flavor
and what you feel like
in the right moment.
And when you burst and say, OK,
Google, talk to Personal Chef,
basically you're going
to Actions on Google
and then the magic of
language understanding
and gathering out from
what the user said
their exact intents and
entities is being done for you.
And from that moment, you
basically go to your service--
here it will be Google Cloud,
but it could be any cloud
service out there--
and the user will
be in your hand,
so you'll need to interpret
what they wanted to
and return back the text
that, again, Actions on Google
will take and produce
a speech out of it.
So all the interaction
with the users
will be done through that layer
that's basically giving you
the ability to work
with nice JSON file
in your server that is easy
to interpret and work with.
But the heavy lifting
of combining and going
from text to speech is being
done through that layer.
I think the best will be just
to look at this show demo.
It will make very
clear what I just said.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- OK, Google, let me
talk to Personal Chef.
- Sure.
Here's Personal Chef.
[BEEP]
- Hi, I'm your Personal Chef.
What are you in the mood for?
- Well, it's kind
of cold outside,
so I'd like something to
warm me up, like a hot soup.
And I want it fast.
- All right.
What protein would
you like to use?
- I have some chicken and
also some canned tomatoes.
- OK, well, I think you should
try the chicken tomato soup
recipe I found on example.com.
[BEEP]
- Sounds good to me.
[END PLAYBACK]
DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE:
All right,
so that was a pretty
simple interaction.
It was like a simple thing to
be having a conversation about.
But the conversation itself
was actually quite complex.
So Wayne, our developer
advocate out there,
said cold, warm, and hot
all in the same sentence,
but the app managed to capture
the correct one referring
to the soup.
So can you imagine
trying to write
a regular expression or
a parser that would try
to extract meaning out of that?
It basically-- there are
so many difficult cases
that it ends up being pretty
much impossible for anything
beyond a trivial example.
So let's look at
some of the ways we
could build this interaction.
So one of the options is
to use the conversation API
and the actions SDK.
And in this case,
your Assistant app
receives a request that
contains the spoken text
from the user as a string.
So Google handles the
speech recognition for you,
but you pass the strings,
you generate a response,
and then Google handles
speaking this back to the user.
The thing is, as
we just mentioned,
parsing natural language
can be really difficult.
So fortunately,
we have some tools
that make handling that
type of thing a lot easier.
API.ai is one of these.
It's a platform that makes
it incredibly straightforward
to build conversational
experiences.
You might not even have to write
any code if you're building
something fairly simple.
So we're going to give you
an overview of this today.
And it's probably
what most of you
should use if you're
going to implement
your own assistant app.
So API.ai basically provides
an intuitive graphical user
interface to create
conversational experiences.
So you program in a few example
sentences of the way users
might express a certain
need, and you can also
specify the values you
need to get from the user.
And then we use machine
learning to train a model,
or we train a machine
learning model,
to understand these sentences
and manage a conversation.
So the key part here
is that you no longer
need to process raw strings.
API.ai will do that for you.
So you can see in our
diagram where API fits in.
It handles the
conversation fulfillment
in between the Assistant
itself and your back end.
And API.ai handles the
conversation for you,
so another way of
looking at this is like,
the user says something,
so maybe they're
asking for a certain recipe.
The Assistant converts
their voice into text,
and API.ai receives
that text string.
It will decompose that, figure
out what it actually means,
and hand you that meaning in
the form of structured data.
You receive that
in your web hook,
you do whatever you need to do,
like look it up in the database
and find a matching recipe,
you build a response,
and then you pass it back
to the Assistant, which
will read it out to the user.
So we're going to show you a
short demo of how we would work
with API.ai to build this app.
All right, so in
API.ai, we create
an intent to
represent each thing
that the user might want to do.
So in this case,
we've built an intent
that covers the user
asking for a recipe.
So I'm going to open
the intent here.
So right here you
can see how we've
provided examples
of different ways
the user might express
their desire for a recipe.
And these examples
are used to train
a machine learning
model that can
recognize what the user wants.
And as we add examples,
API.ai will automatically
pick out important concepts
that are mentioned by the user.
So the system actually
understands many concepts
by itself, but you
can add custom,
domain-specific information,
like in this case, recipe
ingredients.
So I'm going to add a
couple of things here.
IDO GREEN: And as
Dan types, you could
see that it will
mark immediately
the entities that
it understands.
And actually, if it doesn't
understand correctly
the entity that you wish,
you could mark it for it.
So you can see here, protein
and dish type immediately
have been recognized
because we already
have some examples beneath.
DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE:
So another example.
So these are all entities
our system knows about,
and API.ai is able to pluck
those from the user's statement
and figure out what they mean.
So we can actually also mark
this information as required.
So here we've put in a
cooking speed and a dish type.
Down here, we've actually
marked dish type and protein
and vegetable as required.
So in this case, our
app is automatically
going to ask the user if
they didn't mention it.
So I'm going to save
the intent, and we'll
wait one moment for it to train
the machine learning model.
OK, so training's completed.
So now I'm going to enter
in our test console, which
is kind of how we work while
we're developing the agent.
I can just enter in, I
want something with beef.
So in this case I'm
specifying a protein,
but I didn't specify a
vegetable or a dish type.
So the system actually knows
that it expects those things,
and it should prompt for them
if they weren't supplied.
So I can now say potato.
And I still need to know a
dish type, so what kind of dish
do you prefer?
Let's have a main course.
And so now this is where we
would hand off to our back end,
and we would use
that structured data
to look up a recipe
in the database
and return it to the user.
So it's pretty amazing to be
able to conduct a conversation
dynamically in this
way, just based
on the information the
user provided, on the fly,
without knowing in advance
what they're going to say.
Once the intent has captured
all of this information,
it becomes available to
use on your back end, which
is where you're going to make
stuff happen and generate
a response.
So you can see in here, we have
the action that we resolve to,
which is the intent, and we
have this parameter data that we
captured from the user's query.
And so because we have those
values in a structured way,
we can look those
up in our back end
and return something useful.
So once we're done,
it's only a few clicks
to integrate the app with a
load of different platforms,
so on the integration tab here.
So we want to integrate
with Actions on Google
so that this app is available
via the Google Home.
So we can just click
here and load up
the simulator to test this out.
So the Actions on
Google web simulator
allows us to test out
our action as if it's
running on the actual platform.
So I can say talk
to my test app.
COMPUTER: All right.
Let's get the test
version of my test--
DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE:
And so here we're
seeing how the app
would be responding.
And I can say let's try
a recipe with chicken.
And this is now communicating
with API.ai in the same way
that the Google Home might be.
So it's asking what
kind of vegetables
we have, so let's say potato.
And again, we want
a main course.
So we can see how it's
really easy to develop
your app with an API.ai,
test it out in the simulator,
and then the magical
thing is if you're
signed in to a Google
Home or the Assistant app
on your phone, this app is now
immediately available for you
to test out.
So you can try it straight away
and make modifications live,
which is a really fun workflow.
There's not really
any deployment step.
So this is the workflow
for building an Action.
It's super fast and simple,
and you should definitely
attend the following
workshop session
on building an assistant app.
So give it a try
it for yourself.
So let's switch back
over to our slides
and talk a little more
about the platform.
IDO GREEN: So we saw how
we could leverage API.ai,
and the goal with any
app that we're building
is actually to
have the wow effect
and to have the best experience
that we could give our users.
So that should be it
about what can we do.
Before we're starting
to code our app,
and it's actually
quite easy to do,
I think one of the
most important aspects
is to dive into all
the great content
that our team produced
around design voice UIs.
It's a totally different topic
than what we, or most of us,
are used to in terms of
graphical user interface.
And when coming
to voice, there's
lots of constraints,
limitations that we
could take into consideration.
And there's some great
opportunities there,
like a checklist and tips
that could really put you
on the right track
when you're coming
to design the conversation
and to see how those moving
parts are going to work best
in your specific use case.
When we're coming
to build it, we
need to take into
consideration that, like we
saw in the earlier
slide, we'll have
different services out there.
Right now, we have Google
Home and mobile devices,
and soon we'll have more.
And on mobile devices, we
could and actually should
leverage the real estate
that the screen is giving
us, as as you can see
here in the example,
let's say that the user
wanted to get to someplace.
On Google Home, we'll
tell them where to go
and if we have the screen
and we know it in our app
that we are now on this
surface, we could give them
a small map and a
URL so they could
get the directions immediately.
At most basic, you can specify
on the screen what is the text
that you are going to speak?
And as you can see
here in the example,
we have what we'll be
telling to the user
and what will be the text.
One of the most important
aspects to remember here
is that we always want
that the text will
be a summary or the
executive summary of what
we will talk to the user.
So if the user is
listening, they're
getting the full-blown
answer, and if they're just
skimming with their
eyes the screen,
they still get to
see what we want
or the most important aspect,
but like in the example
here, we don't need to give
them the full-blown answer.
When we have one of
the options or one
of the most popular options,
one of the main design tips
that we're giving is to
lead the conversation
and to give the user the ability
to very quickly go en route
to the path that they want to.
So suggestion chips are one
of the most efficient ways
to do it.
If you have some
popular choices,
you could suggest
it to the user.
So on the screen, they
have this nice button
that they could click on.
And if of course we
are on Google Home,
you could suggest it,
and the user will choose.
They don't necessarily
force to it, right?
They could choose, in this
example, any other number that
is out there.
But at least we suggest
to them what to do.
And in our example,
it could be suggesting
the most common vegetables that
are appearing in the recipe.
Basic cards are actually
quite holistic and complex,
in the sense that they are
giving the full-blown image,
URL, and text, and its
giving you the ability
to extend the experience.
So in our case, we could show
a nice big photo of the dish
itself and to give
the user a link
so they could open
it in their app
and see what we
are going to cook.
There are many
cases where you want
to set and show the
user a list of things
and give the user a
visual selection of what's
going on with the
different type of things
that they could choose from.
And the carousels
show big images.
The main difference
is that we have
a more limited set of items.
And with lists, we'll have
smaller images and much longer
lists that we could
show the user what
are the different options.
And in this example,
you could think
about showing a couple
of different options
for a type of dish.
And that will be-- let's
say that the user already
chose a chicken salad.
We could use the
carousel to offer
three, four different types
of recipes for chicken salad.
On the other hand, if we want
to show a dozen different dishes
that feature chicken
as an ingredient,
we could use the list.
DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE:
So you might
have a conversation where you
need to know the user's name
or location.
So one example might be if
you were helping the user find
a local bookstore,
and you want to know
the zip code or the postcode.
So you can use our SDK
to request permissions
for the name, the
coarse location,
and the precise
location of the user.
And when you invoke
this function,
the Assistant's going to
ask the user for permission
in the voice of your app.
So it's really seamless.
The name is the name of the user
who's registered to the device.
The precise location is
the exact GPS coordinates
and the street address.
And then the coarse location is
just the zip code or postcode
and the city.
If you'd like to link a
user with their account
on your own service and
you have an OAuth server,
the Google Assistant can prompt
users to link their account.
So at this point,
the requesting user
is going to receive a card at
the top of their Google Home
app on their phone that provides
a link to your login page.
And they can follow that,
log into your service.
Once the user's completed
the account linking flow
on your web app, they
can invoke your Action,
and your Action can authenticate
calls to your services
through our API.
So it's important that you
provide the OAuth end point.
Right now, as part of
the approvals process,
we basically want you to
run your own OAuth server.
So if your experience
involves shopping or payments,
we support rich
transactions, and we allow
you to accept user payments.
And the really cool
part about this
is that customers can use
whatever payment information
they have on file with Google.
So payments can be super easy.
There's no need to fumble
around with a credit card
or read numbers out
loud, although they
can use your payment
solution if you prefer.
Transaction supports
are shopping
carts, delivery options,
order summary, and payments.
The user can see a history
of all their transactions.
The Assistant also
supports home automation
via our Smart Home integration.
So if you're a device
maker, you can easily
integrate your existing
devices with our Home Graph.
And the Home Graph
basically knows the state
of all connected
devices, so that when
you're asked to dim the
lights a little bit,
it knows how to do
that intelligently.
So there's kind of
endless possibilities
around how you can allow
the user to interact
with home automation.
We've also announced the
Google Assistant SDK,
which enables you to embed the
Assistant in your own custom
hardware projects.
So "MagPi" magazine announced
the AIY Projects kit
from Google, which
provides a cardboard
housing with a button, a
speaker, and a microphone,
and it wraps around
a Raspberry Pi
and uses the Google
Assistant SDK.
And at Google I/O, we
demoed this mocktails mixer
from our partner Deeplocal,
which embeds the Assistant SDK,
and you can walk
up to the device,
tell it what kind
of drink you want,
and it will mix it up for you.
So you can embed the Assistant
into pretty much any hardware
device.
IDO GREEN: After we've
built our Assistant up,
it's time to reach user and
see how we could drive traffic
to it and what are there
different options for us
at the moment.
So the basic way to
invoke the app is to--
after, of course,
you've submitted the app
and it passed the review--
is to provide a set of triggers
that the invocation knows.
So when you'll say, OK,
Google, talk to, in our case,
Personal Chef, it could
be another one or two
different invocations,
and the user
will ask according to your
brand name or to your app name,
and it will invoke it.
We also support deep linking.
So as you can see
here in the example,
you could say in one sentence
to talk to Personal Chef
and get the recipe of the
hot soup or something else.
There are also the
ability to ask Google
for I want to work out.
I want a yoga or something
more [INAUDIBLE]..
And then obviously, if you
have a quality good assistant
app in the directory,
Google will surface it.
And that's come to
the point that it's
a blue ocean and great
opportunities out there.
Last but not least, we
have a full directory
of apps that are sitting and
living inside the Assistant.
On the top right corner,
you have the ability
to click and open the directory.
And again, it's opening and give
the user based on categories
and based on what
the system thinks
the user will enjoy most.
What are the
different variations
of apps that are out
there to try and use?
There are quite a lot.
So I really suggest you
to check some of them out.
You could and should link.
And we have a deep
link so you could,
if you have a web
service or another app,
you could always link from
it to the Assistant app.
So in lots of cases
where the service might
be more efficient for your
users from the Assistant app,
I highly encourage
you to link to it.
And then of course,
they could use it.
DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE:
So we've
seen all this awesome stuff
you can do with the Actions
platform, but let's
talk a little bit
about how you can get started.
So we've got a series of videos
that cover a lot of content
on how to get up and
running with the Assistant.
So you've got an
intro video that
explains high-level concepts and
goes through the Personal Chef
example.
There's a video dedicated to
conversation design, which
is definitely worth
checking out as you start
to design and build your app.
And we've also got a screencast
of every single step needed
to build our Personal
Chef example.
We also have several
code labs that
will guide you through the
experience of designing
and implementing your
first assistant app.
And finally, when you want to
discuss this stuff with other
developers, we have a really
active Actions on Google
Developer Community on Google+.
So we post regularly
there to keep you up
to date with the latest
news, and we answer questions
from developers.
We've also got a great
community on Stack Overflow
if you have technical questions.
After us, there's really great
talk by Sachit and Shuyang
that will guide you in
much more detail in how
to build an assistant app.
So you should definitely head
upstairs and check that out
after this talk.
And our whole team of assistant
dev rail people is here,
so please feel free to
come by and ask questions
about the platform.
We can show you the Google
Home, and we can show
you the Assistant SDK stuff.
So thank you all for coming and
really encourage you to dive
into this new platform.
[APPLAUSE]
IDO GREEN: Last but
not least, I forgot
to mention it at the beginning.
I saw people taking photos.
All the slides are live.
You could ping Dan or myself
on any channel that you wish
and you could get
all the slides there.
And if you have any questions,
we'll be at our booth
at the Assistant
App room, so please
feel free to come over and give
us your feedback and thoughts.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE: Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]